Oh
what'd I do this week on thug notes we
gettin love-struck Romeo and Juliet by
William Shakespeare up in the swanky
part of Verona two families called the
Montagues and the Capulets been beefing
since fire I've been dodging all-out war
in the streets
Big Daddy Montague and his blue lady
Montague start talking about the emo son
Romeo who got it bad for some Foxx
Rosalie but Rosaline ain't feelin it and
now Romeo moping around like even lost
his nuts so Romeo Romeo has been volio
and Mercutio try to get his mind off
that trick by crashing a party over at
the Capulets crib but as soon as Romeo
peeps the most tab a blast of Juliet
Capulet he forgets all about that
Rosaline mess and steps up to Harlem
like a champ
Romeo loves himself some fast women so
he drops his a-game gets a little lip
action and smash those digits get it
Romeo then Romeo creeps up to Juliet's
balcony
turns out she bashed and crazy in love
him too but since their families got so
much beef they got to keep it all on a
deal next day Romeo and Juliet run off
to the local preacher man friar
Lawrence's spot and get hitched later
then boldly oh and Mercutio taking it
easy
when timbal the bad ismo full of all the
Capulets steps up and starts talking
Mercutio boot up and starts scrapping
with temple till Romeo buses in and
tries to break it up but Romeo just gets
it away and temple shakes Mercutio damn
Romeo goes from whiny [ __ ] - the
hardest thug in the streets that
straight mercs tip o the Prince of
aronia had it with all his gang violence
so he boots Romeo right out of town when
Juliet's mama say she gotta marry some
candy-ass
scrub named Paris Julia gets all torn up
and hits up Friar Lawrence for some help
fry daddy comes up with the plan to fake
Julius
by giving her some juice that makes her
take a long-ass nap then he gonna write
Romeo 11 saying all he has to do is play
it cool and once Juliet wakes up Romeo
will have a lifetime supply poontang
problem is the latter never makes it to
Romeo so when he hears Juliet bit the
dust
he faces it's for real Romeo straight
flips so he rolls up to Julia's crib
peeps are laying stiff and throws back
some poison when Juliet wakes up he sees
his dead body she gets all crunk grabs a
knife and kills herself
teenagers man damn Willy shakes flippin
opposites all up in this play love hey
youth age life death I ain't even
trippin even characters got opposites
for example while Benvolio be all chill
and peace-loving Tibbles always coming
out hard trying to throw down she you
can even peep these paradoxes in a text
be my only love sprung from my only hate
my grave is like to be my wedding bed
but Willie ain't just playing all these
clashing opposites making that dramatic
action mo intense listen up partner the
full title of this play is the most
excellent and lamentable tragedy of
Romeo and Juliet set is it really a
tragedy some homies don't think so see
in most tragedies the characters got
something in that dome that's so [ __ ]
up that no matter what they're gonna end
up filling the hurt peeps call this the
tragic flaw thing is some folks say
Romeo and Juliet ain't rollin with no
tragic flaws it ain't their fault that
get soaked right but what is tragic is
that something else is tripping up their
game chance all throughout this place
they doing our love of straight dirty
just look at all these ridiculous
coincidences that letter don't find
Romeo the friar too late and stopping
them Juliet wakes up right after Romeo
bit the big one I could go on play so in
the prologue Santa these kids be
star-crossed maybe it's cuz the heavens
got an infinite fools
but maybe it ain't fate so much as it is
kids acting like stupid look some say
Romeo and Juliet's tragic flaw being
loved all insane in the membrane and
they willing to do anything to keep it
real even for our lawyers say that could
have said these violent delights have
violent ends and in their triumph ire
and powder which as they kiss consume
the sweetest honey is loathsome in his
own deliciousness and then the taste
confounds the appetite therefore love
moderately love love dark soul to Swift
arrives as tardy as too slow
could be vain sending it all but that
the world that they live in is just too
twisted to deal with the love is pure as
this may be you mean our lovers that got
the flower son maybe it's the world but
all scholars agree it would be a damn
tragedy if you didn't subscribe peace
y'all
[Music]